okay so my basin security I usually
don't tell people this a lot but when I
was younger I was really shy and my like
biological dad was kind of abusive and
so there's a lot of times where he would
do stuff to like my family or my mom and
stuff and I always just felt like like
the feeling that I remember feeling the
earliest was like that I was kind of
like a coward and so now anytime that
I'm like that I want to stand up to my
for my friends or something I always get
like a bit nervous because I feel like
that's like one of the emotions that I
associated with myself the earliest but
just like sucks to be like four years
old and feel like you can't do anything
but I know that I should have done
something but it's just kind of like I
was just kind of stuck so I always like
deal with like stage fright or like when
I know I'm supposed to stand up for
something but I feel like I can't those
feelings just like come back say yeah
well it's like growing up I always felt
like really pretty older sister um and I
was always like really insecure that
like I wasn't gonna like to be as good
as her and I felt like everyone compared
us like all the time and so I think I
just like was always scared that like
people would like choose like hurl for
me I guess it's like kind of reoccurring
with like friends and stuff I felt like
they liked her better because like she
was older she was prettier like stuff
like that um so I guess that was the
reduce insecurity I guess yeah
[Music]
when I was younger I didn't really like
I couldn't talk very well and so I had
like no one could understand I was
saying and I had to have like all of my
friends and my siblings like tell people
what I was trying to say because no one
knew words that were coming out so I
think that kind of affected me and made
me not want to talk in front of people
so I think it's still in the back of my
mind when I talk in front of people
after like do things where it's if you
were watching but I think I've kind of
my friends and family hoping getting
over it so yeah my biggest insecurity is
probably my weight I never had to worry
about it all my life and I never really
thought about it until I put on a few
pounds after having five kids and as a
mom it's hard to take care of yourself
and I put everybody else first and so
yeah it's weird to think that just
putting on a few pounds would make me
feel completely different about Who I am
and not be confident in my other
giftings but that's what I'm doing is
right now it's just like how could this
how could this stop me doing things that
I love or being in pictures with my
beautiful wonderful children and and
then I get sad because I miss memories
because I don't want to see a picture of
myself and that's sad
because my kids will they don't care
they just want to know that I love them
and I do and I want to love myself
enough to not care that I look not my
best in pictures I'm a little like naive
to things you know like it's easy for
some people to like take advantage of me
a lot for example and maybe like maybe
like when they're like selling something
they're like pressuring me to do them
like oh okay so like it's hard for me to
just like say no I I've actually been
thinking about it a lot recently I don't
really know myself like I don't know who
I am I've been trying to figure it out
and it's it's something that I kind of
stay up at night thinking about I don't
know like I pour all my energy and time
into like other people and other
going on around me but I never focus on
myself so I guess like I'm my biggest
insecurity if that makes sense I think
yeah that's weird saying that out loud
oh my gosh that's crazy
maybe my height absolutely
sometimes I can't see above me or
anything like that it's hard being sure
and I feel like a lot of people
literally look down on me I'm definitely
my height just because like being a girl
or being a woman and being like
significantly taller than the other guys
could be intimidating at first it was
really really difficult like being so
different than everyone else but now I
like oh man by my weight my biggest
insecurity I guess the fact that I'm
skinny I can do about it I'd probably
say my hair it doesn't behave sometimes
it does my biggest insecurity is
actually my feet yeah I had eczema on my
left foot and I don't really like
showing off my toes because I mean you
look around people have beautiful feet
maybe that wear sandals and stuff and me
I I gotta like put like layers of lotion
on and stuff like that just to even have
my foot looking normal
so yeah that's one of my biggest
insecurity my skin actually so it's
really weird I have eczema all over I
feel like every time I look in the
mirror I see all the time it's all I can
see why I look at myself my shyness I
guess we're like um
yeah the way I act when I'm like nervous
I said I don't know I get weird and I
feel like it like it stops them from
being like my personality I guess so
yeah I think my biggest insecurity is
probably the way that I like project
myself towards other people like first
impression wise like sometimes I feel
like I can come off like way too strong
or like sometimes I feel like people
tend to think that I'm weird or like
people tend to think that like I look
weird or I talk weird I act learned you
know so I'm very cautious about like the
things that I do on like a daily basis
I'm constantly like thinking about like
if I'm doing something wrong or if I'm
saying something wrong but if I like if
I annoyed someone or something like that
so I would say that like my personality
there we go is probably what I'm most
insecure about that I'm not enough for
people like like I want them to want me
to be around and like I just feel like
I'm never like good enough yeah I try
not to feel like that but sometimes I
just feel like I'm like a burden to
people
I think my biggest insecurity is how
quiet I am like I get confused I'm like
should I be saying something but no I
don't so it's fine
[Music]
I'm insecure about my ability to make
myself seem vulnerable or in any
situation where I can be perceived as
sensitive or weak I guess I become
really insecure about that type of thing
because I'm hard-headed probably and I'm
stubborn and I I like to have people
believe that I am more resilient and
like tougher than I am
because it helps me it protects me
I don't know probably just people kind
of very just brushing me off to the side
like trying to make sure that people
like you notice me I guess I have a
brother who's two years older than me
and so a lot of the times in like school
I would get called by my brother's name
and so I think a big thing was like
trying to make sure that I had my own
identity growing up and not just being
my older brothers younger brother my
biggest insecurity are my feelings I
don't like how other people can perceive
my feelings even though I know I feel
like deep inside but like to someone
else it could be something completely
different and so like it just gives me
anxiety about oh my god they don't
understand what I'm saying or how I'm
feeling so like everything just like
comes off wrong and then like just leads
to bad situation you know growing up I
really haven't like I wasn't really able
to like express myself like how I feel
or anything because especially like in
Chicago like feelings like don't exist
so if you feel something just have to
like keep that inside for yourself and
you just have to like deal with it on
your own
my lease because I got made fun of a lot
when I was younger about it and kind of
just I went to care about it even as an
adult oh gosh
well I mean as you can see I've
struggled with acne since like early
childhood and I guess like when I get my
like for my anxiety acts up I start to
like compete again my skin's thinking
about like whatever things when they
look at me or like even when I'm around
family and they make a comment or
something like that it just kind of
really gets to me I feel like my body
image like as long as I can remember has
always been like my biggest like my
weight my mom is like super skinny and
she's always like talking about how
she's like that
so then growing up she's always kind of
made comments not like mean to me at all
but just kind of like about herself and
then that kind of like has trickled down
to me and how I feel about myself and
yeah I don't really think I haven't
insecurity because I'm just a really
perfect person and it's just really hard
being me so I guess my biggest
insecurity is that people think I'm just
better than them no no I think my
biggest insecurity is probably I think
being unliked by people and people
judging me which is common but yeah my
biggest insecurity is that I wouldn't be
loved
I'll be lonely I'm getting in love that
first when I don't feel the other person
knocks me to not be have love
reciprocated maybe like never finding
love my parents didn't so I'm scared to
Iowa you know I find myself being scared
of being alone and unhappy being alone
perhaps because I think people need
people
hi everyone thanks for watching another
episode basically I just want to say
welcome to the new subscribers and to
the subscribers who have been with me
for a while I want to thank you for
constantly supporting my channel and to
the new viewers who haven't subscribed
to my channel yet I hope you get to the
point where you want to hit the
subscribe button and possibly the Bell
next to it so you get notified every
time I put up a new episode I don't know
if you guys have noticed but a lot of my
recent episodes have been suggestions
from you guys so I want to thank you for
that as well I have noticed that you
guys love suggesting questions for my
strangers answer series which I love but
I do want to let you know that you could
literally suggest anything you want it
doesn't just have to be a question it
could be like a whole new project idea
I'm always open to trying new things as
long as it lines up with what my channel
is about which is doing things with
strangers and sharing good stories I
think that's pretty much it thank you
guys again for everything
and I'll see you next week
[Music]
you